are currently 107 gladiators war zone
raided this is the cube fanatics
I am entered average rating 18 16 30
minutes of craziness let's roll
coming up double those points get this
little thing out of here
over here window time ticker here we go
oh no a clock burner a non mover okay
time to do some homework what other
games are going on my game is not
starting see five they are fearing the
pre-move see five right here
okay okay okay who's got a point already
let's see one one okay I'm gonna be up
there at one point I'll be joining these
300 impeccable it's too okay less than
five they better not check the server
let's go here let's go back to
tournament back determine I got one I'll
take the one all right
pair me up here we go it's wolf man the
big bad wolf I've played many a times I
thought once again where the game is not
gonna get fired out there all right
let's do it let's do it my queen is in a
good position fishing go fish go fish go
fish fish why not okay I'm still fishing
for it still fishing all right let's get
rid of let's try that oh oh oh I have
the Queen that was a most slipper quick
resign quick resign you know you want to
resign f5 whoa I got how many I got four
points for that one I'll take the four
points I think you earned extra points
if you get a really really quick win I
think that was really really quick
really really quick right was it
let's go f7 target have seven and
everything's gonna be quite all right
but hang on hang on
you don't want to lose your bishop don't
lose that fish up so quickly all right
Knight are you gonna take on f3 my queen
is gonna have fun right here it's fun
right here hmm oh they're the Queen
Esther run home she's got to run home
she didn't run home I got the rook uh-oh
uh-oh
mmm get out of there Queen take that
pawn I'm okay with it I'm okay with a
Queen trade I wanted to do this I wanted
to be able to take and be on the Queen
okay now that now this I want to save my
knight my nice ready to run away oh he's
ready to be stopped I want to still run
away run away Knight
I'm up a full rook runaway night this is
safe here
castle I could give a check I should
have given a check and then take here
okay where does that mean where does
that mean
check Oh more pieces this is check and
then this is leading to me in one -
Bishop blocks and then this is
unavoidable yes back to tournament
eleven the assassin is up there
everybody should fear the assassin 11:10
okay let's keep going here a lot of time
left a real lot 25 minutes and change
knight c6 i build a center and then you
support the center typical idea build a
center support your center let's get the
rook doing something okay I want to get
rid of their LightSquared bishop and
then focus on f3 let's do that right now
maybe I could have played rook here
first my queen is in a really good spot
Knight here is a follow up I want to
take up the night and play Knight here
okay I'm on the rook mates right Knight
here I could just take because my rook
is there could just take the rook has to
recapture I'm pretty sure I end up
getting the Queen though whoa this is a
problem I'm smashing through still at
this g3 point capture and then take like
here now I'm gonna go like this and then
oh that yeah this is me my husband I was
ready to move my rook back and then over
okay back to tournament nineteen twelve
twelve eleven twenty four double those
points E for Knight c3 same old baloney
okay they're trying to get in d5 put
pressure on this pond and then maybe get
here or even a pond push oh they're
gonna have trouble castling kingside
I got the bishop might be quick resigner
we're not let's do this get here
it's gonna be a floor coming up not the
Sun I got the night the night has to run
home or does he have to run home I want
to push him around though I pushed that
night around he's getting pushed around
okay I gotta get rid of that push in the
center open the position up let's back
up pawn push coming up very soon right
now with check let's just take and then
let's give checking then bishop here I
think King takes was best I'm on the
clean and I'm gonna queenside castle I
have this queen I can't no I can't
council to check castle through check
don't do that
anything but that checks castle in this
direction and then give a check and
where's the where's the naca Oh [ __ ] I
should have given a rook check let's
open this up here get my queen involved
the rook is gonna come over or not where
is that mean just get rid of that night
get out there night oh my other Knight
should play the game my other Knight
should have played there
I'm not seasick so I was on c6 fork if
the rook plays there this game is not
gonna end I just don't want any of their
time to uh any of my time to come off
there just anything I'm not gonna end up
giving Meg back determine 29 23 20 20 19
a lot of contenders up there 22 minutes
a lot of time left here we go I want to
get that Bishop I think okay now let's
do this maybe it's awkward now that he
can't get in d5
I could play here hit that Bishop I want
know why am I going after that Bishop
he's stupid
the bishop wasn't doing anything anyhow
right don't go here cuz it's a fork with
pawn push that's a bit annoying I'm
gonna take care hopefully they recapture
right away okay now I have to worry I
don't have to worry about the rook but I
want to get rid of that bishop I can't
move my rook until I deal with the
pressure on here okay my bishops in a
really good spot now I want to get
Bishop c6 Knight here if allowed let's
do it well so swell I'm okay with giving
out my dark square bishop but I think
let's do this my queen will be in a good
spot I'd like to get my knight here I
think it's intolerable maybe I should
have yeah I should have done that should
have played my knight there sooner did I
have the opportunity to do that you get
this pawn next or maybe light squares I
take here Knight takes there let's do
this no let's do this I want to get my
rook here and then target that pawn
maybe have a passed pawn bring this beep
on up to b6 have connected passed pawns
pawn up a couple times just take that
night out if the pawn pushes because
otherwise it plays here oh they're on
this pond though let's do this and then
take here if the RIP takes there I need
a flight Square real bad time situation
time time time time time time let's just
come here be extra cautious I'm on that
pond twice the rug defense I can't take
right away otherwise back rank maids
trickiness beware of the trickiness now
I could take and then play here if
there's a rook check important point
right there I need time burners
where are the time burners five time
burners
where are they okay back to chairman
that was bad technique by the way that
was definitely bad technique right there
I got 41 36 35 a lot of game left a lot
of tournament left 20 minutes a third of
the way there
Grand Prix let's give it a shot let's
give it a shot okay full effect coming
up Fein kettled Bishop I'm looking to
get my bishop eventually to h6 Queen
pivot typical ID in the Grand Prix if
you're not familiar with it be aware of
it Queen e1 and then shifting over to
this h4 square very very common my
bishops in trouble I should have taken
upon what am i doing that was a free pod
wasn't it
ah man okay this is this is trouble can
I still get something going on here I'm
gonna try for it definitely gonna try
for 85 is probably the scariest thing
for me okay my bishop wow what a good
guy right here it's fantastic
Oh is he fantastic or what what a what a
good day he's having right yeah he's
having a fantastic day oh what a lovely
day that bishops are having on p1
fortunately my opponent is down on time
once again time is my best friend in
these games that's all I have it's just
nothing oh I'd really just want to take
that night but I'm not going to time
situation my bishop is slowly coming to
life actually it's gonna see the war
it's gonna see the world eventually it's
seeing it come on move don't move too
quick
get out of there night get out of there
night Oh with a mouse slipper Mao
slippers Mao slippers everywhere back to
2000 59 56 55 9 games are in for tile
and ec5 let's roll here ok
chop here I drop back to positions after
that game would that take too long
a six castle this is I'm knockin that's
like an anti fishing pole or something I
can't I can't break down that G that
structure right there so easily okay
pawn push a couple times I'm looking to
trap that up bishop there may be backup
I want to chop that bishop let's see
what the night's gonna do okay I want to
target this pawn Knight here probably a
good idea hit that with width tempo on
the Queen rook here okay I'll be on it
twice oh they're on my night I should
have just taken it right away I could
still get this I think bishops ready to
be trapped right here it's trapped I
have a time edge too
I'm on that pond I have back rank
covered I'm on it three times I think
this is okay I want to target f2 next
looking for pigs
where are the pigs get a pig here first
and then Queen
oh that's just dropping a rook
miscalculation right Queen here looking
for mates
oh they grab that pond wits check I
should still be quite all right they
resigned back to tournament 72 71 eight
games eight games eight games up top
sure Dennis oh yeah some thought the
nest
come on each pond you can do it save the
day save the day each pond you know you
want to be a contributor you know you
want to play a role in the success of
this game hopefully they have to get run
home they have to run home and I think
this Knight has to run home and then
maybe this one they're having to run
home if the knight goes here I play here
and he's dead he's a dead man
Knight takes here's available though I
think I'll take like that though or like
this okay they take spawn is there Oh
quick resign quick resign quick resign
they're not quick resigning let's go
let's go Queen here Oh
Queen e2 that pounds falling I should
have played somewhere else like here
let's take this get that Bishop out here
so I could castle get out of there
bishop okay oh no I have that covered
let's cover this guy - or take here I
could take there with check next its
castle first 25 seconds pass pawn keep
pushing I could take it my Knights cover
and get back here watch over this light
squares I've actually maybe just keep
pushing keep pushing
push again push again clean check was
available I could have picked that rook
off okay I have this rook instead with
check this is definitely reasonable
isn't it I have a lot of pieces here a
lot of Queens where's the main mate
coming up next
it's got to be happening real soon
real soon it's got to be happening
that's that's not me
oh they had to take that guy away come
on come on come on come on come on back
to term in 89 110 97 89 14 minutes we're
about halfway there halfway there I need
some quick wins here where are the quick
kills quick kills where are they
safeguard the Queen don't get excited
don't get too excited here let's go
fishing go fishing is where it's at
here's the here's the pole launching the
pole and then here's the bait oh okay
the anti fishing pole defend against g4o
light squares or dark squares excuse me
you know what I meant let's come back
here and the Queen wants to weasel
around let's do this take that pond or
take that night Queen back home looking
for me and it's difficult to avoid the
night oestrogen oh I just dropped a
piece the lateral movement of the Queen
Oh everybody should fear the lateral
movement of the Queen or should they oh
man ah man I'm down a piece
get out of there bishop
pins everywhere oh I lucked out with
that move I lucked out with that move
yes I did
oh but that one is scary now I got to do
this
I had a queen check get out of there
Bishop do I have it do I have this
bishop back at least say it's so oh that
Knight has to get out of there I gotta
kill this Bishop and then I'm gonna be
sneaky making to threat sneaking
sneaking this sneakiness more sneakiness
checkmate to threat where's the matin -
do you see it do you see it mate in one
- quick quick just move
there's mate here but I have mate first
a time burner back to tournament 117 114
110 109 Wow what a tight pack up here
let's go clutch I need a clutch win
right now against clutch let's go f7
still a lot of time a little less than
13 minutes a little less than 13 can it
be done okay get out of there Bishop I
cannot deal with you okay
get out of there Knight go somewhere
else go somewhere else night Oh Oh hoo I
insist
just get out oh I have a pin pin pin pin
pin pin if the knight moves its mate
unless he plays here I got the night
get out of there bishop remove that but
maybe I should have played there again I
should have played there again mmm let's
do this now is it working now it's not
working now
I had a knight move and then here or
something where where's the let's just
try this let's try to give what am i
doing just take the night you know you
want to take the knight please fall for
it
yes yes yes like I needed that kind of
I have to try sneaky stuff stuff that is
not optimal I have to hope there's a
little bit of hope involved in these
games you have to hope that the mistakes
are made and there was there was a
mistake made there now this guy is
probably sick and tired of me doing this
same stuff this guy has clearly shown
time and time again that he knows how to
defend against this fishing pole but I'm
he's probably sick and tired of it but
I'm still gonna I'm still gonna try it I
just can't imagine he must be saying
like oh my goodness this guy again
trying that same fishing pole stuff I
don't want the C file to open up so
let's keep it closed let's play here so
the pond doesn't have the possibility of
moving let's play here and ok we might
have a point exchange and stuff
happening there oh it's scary it's
definitely scary let's go here is
everything ok
and I it's gonna know then I can't play
here I really don't want a castle but
let's just come over here I think it's a
little cozier I need to keep winning
till ok this is scary its once again
scary
I got a defend here that's not working
let's do this oh man coming under some
heavy fire real soon I need to defend
that pond I really want to Queen shade
or something can I get a Queen trade
let's trade here I guess let's do that
rook flap lateral move my rook just
working that night could be taped that
can be taken can it it can oh man I'm
scared
hit the Queen I have this covered hit
the Queen again where's the mate that's
eight Queen mate Queen mate where is he
where's the night going I just want to
take that night I think now I don't I
don't even know what that move is doing
man I don't I gotta take here Oh
seven seconds let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go I don't have
any time no I just dropped my queen no
you didn't see that oh just go quick I
just dropped my queen run for the hills
King
Primo's primo spree moves oh we're gonna
have a bunch of exchanges here who can
move the faster Mouse faster mouse
technique faster Mouse faster Mouse push
up on push up on here push up on there
give a check time burners where are they
time burners time burners time burners
time burners come on his clock isn't
going down shouldn't it go down it
should go down don't get that pine he
got that pine how come his clock isn't
moving
ah to drop Oh No ah man 177 somebody has
and I have 129 ah a draw a drop brutal
Wow that clock was just not moving that
clock was like no you will not you will
not let go that last 1/10 of a second
you will stick around and make life
difficult man oh oh and this is just
gonna turn out to be more trouble I
gotta get here and then here why didn't
that last second tick off that last
tenth of a second all I want it was just
the 1/10 I was trying time burners I
must have done the wrong the wrong
sequence of time burners or something
get out of there Rico I'm just looking
for third now no I have an idea I have
an idea let's do this here's my idea
come up right here watch out for
sneakiness my bishop is gonna weasel
around he's gonna be a weasel er my
queen is trapped no she's not I thought
she was now let's not go here let's come
here my bishops gonna go weasel around I
have a check on d5 if the rook moves
let's come here and then come here check
a ruski and
then here I want to hit this hit this
rook that rook needs these what these
rooks are getting way too active you
need to get out of here check okay now
it's coming together let's hit this pawn
play here hit third time Queens off I
could take here okay
let's go here I still have an advantage
can I get that time yes I got that pun
oh you see watch out for sneaky stuff
that was sneaky stuff right there right
here they're flying where does that King
going he needs to slow down can I get
this one is there clocking a move come
on yes back to tournament Oh
210 197 174 6 minutes and change I need
a lot of catching up to do in order to
even get third that trial how much of a
setback was that draw ah
instead of getting 10 points I got no
points or did I go up down a point I'm
insisting on it still can you believe
that believe it I'm still looking for it
Oh what can you do I can't stop laughing
it's happening now it happens doesn't it
okay I'm really struggling here
struggling oh this is a disaster
Oh Bishop checks and everything you name
it it's happening and it's all bad
oh it's bad news bad news bears here
okay let's pin maybe it's not so bad or
is it let's do a queen trade clean trade
that's all I want
um let's try this I like my knight a
real lot and let's do this - I like
double pods there and let's do this so
I'd support my bishop once I play here
is everything okay this is the assassin
everybody everybody should fear the
assassin king position if I did this
move too early there was gonna be like a
bishop chop right there the king is a
fighting piece he's a fighter
he's a fighter hit this pawn pile up on
the a pond is the plan no no no no no no
I could just take it if the ref plays
there I would've give it a check how's
the clock situation it's doing pretty
good okay next up get this pawn to push
and flush that King backwards it's not
gonna be easy though just can't be easy
maybe can we check okay who pins pin
city pin City pin city there's a rook
check play here King and pawn endgame is
one without a doubt it's one okay they
resigned back determined to 40 I need to
catch 214 it's not happening it's
definitely not happening let's go okay
sicilian land I should try open Sicilian
or not op you do it
let's come back bishop sneakiness bishop
sneakiness Bishop h6 get rid of that
dark square bishop and now i'm gonna get
crunched with the pawn push or something
let's do this my bishop is gonna get
killed and it's definitely getting
killed again this is not the first time
you're seeing this weasel around be a
weasel er be a weasel is the plan come
on Knight save the day save the day my
bishop is coming to life I'm telling ya
he's coming to life my bishops coming to
life he's an animal come on
push pon push my bishop is dead just
pile up here am I getting this pond
launched the ponds it's an it's an
avalanche of ponds guard here make sure
everything is nice and cozy is it nice
and cozy right here pond push coming up
I could deal a queen with the Queen
trade can i king position king position
where's the king position can I do this
is it gonna be okay let's give it a shot
I think it'll be all right Oh Oh watch
out for the mates watch out for the
sneaky mates hang up right here and then
over as soon as that moves okay being
sneaky being sneaky let's get this pond
rolling and hang on to him get this pond
going he's still going
Kings up Kings up and oh I should have
gotten that guy going sooner
let's keep going with this clock
situation where we got there being
sneaky more sneakiness clean I got this
let's just take that and cut them off
right here no stalemates and it'll steal
mates no steal mates no stalemates
that's me that's me they're down on time
I mean 189 um I still have a lot of
catching up to minutes and change no
actually just two minutes exactly here
we go Oh quick resign +10 it's still not
happening though one minute fifty can I
get this no it's gonna be fourth 4th
place is the first loser in these
confetti like tournaments a fourth place
is the first loser you definitely don't
want to be the first loser anything
about 4th place
let's go here let's go Queenie to kill a
knight launch an H pawn hang on me
Castle you know you want a castle I
can't stop laughing pin and night grab a
pawn back up oh no no no no no no come
here because it's good here that's
fantastic advice isn't it come here
because it's good here everybody should
take that advice right there why should
you go there cuz it's good here no
reason just because it's good here night
in the center and then juicy squares
everywhere
juicy squares right here pivot point
shut down the bishop if he plays here or
just take them that would be good to
castle your king was in a pin let's get
him safe let's do it this well there
might be rook up and over 33 seconds
there's just no time no time to win this
one ice well actually they couldn't
think enough to fly here I can still
maybe get a win just I guess her dating
points it's not gonna end up good with
the final results here get out of there
just trades I don't want any time to
come off at my clock just run over here
I guess over here to get a little crazy
my queen is gonna be dead just come over
here anything anything there down on
time there down on time I got 20 Oh
just barely that's it it's complete it's
official fourth first loser ah 297 258
234 these are all very good scores 21
games 1917 good games all alright